meine jungs sind so ausdruckslos
aber es gibt auch mehrere hunde zum
spielen menschen ziemlich abstoßend ja
das ist wieder so weit ich werde mir
heute zum zweiten mal in der geschichte
meines kanals eine folge von einer
ehemaligen prosieben serie anschauen die
vermutlich zu den heftigsten serien
gehört die jemals gesehen habe die rede
ist von hot five und falls es noch nicht
wusste beziehungsweise mein erstes wie
persönlich gesehen habt hot five ist
eine serie bei der verschiedene frauen
antreten sich dann in verschiedenen
kategorien selbst bewerte zum beispiel
wer hat das schönste lächeln oder wer
den schönsten körper und sich dann an
der tür gegenüber stellen besteht aus
drei männern die dann wiederum ihre
einschätzung abgeben und der das
spannende daran ist dass die
selbsteinschätzung der frauen und die
einschätzung der männer immer ein
bisschen auseinander fällt das klingt
vielleicht erstmal recht normal aber man
muss es wirklich in der deutlichkeit
sagen diese sendung ist fremdscham pur
das wird ja bei wenigen momenten selbst
den leuten in kurzer blick in die
beschreibung zeigt uns auch nochmal an
in welche richtung es heute gehen wird
dass nämlich die rede von fünf knackigen
mädels dieses wissen wollen ja wohl
gemerkt knackig nicht hübsch oder
attraktiv sondern knackig soll will man
über bockwürste reden aber werfen wir
einen blick rein die wir schicken fünf
knackige frauen ins tor in mailand
wir müssen sie in vier kategorien
gegeneinander antreten und gesicht beine
sexappeal und outfits also man merkt
auch schon ein bisschen an der kamera
qualität und vor allem an den inhalten
dass das und fernsehformat ist was
heutzutage sind nicht mehr im fernsehen
laufen könnte also ich würd ja auch
nicht den edlen ritter spielen und so
jede kleinigkeit auseinandernehmen aber
kurze frage was war nochmal die
kategorien gesicht bei einer sex appeal
und da ist auch schon wieder vorbei
keine rede von irgendwie ausstrahlung
fähigkeit sich auszudrücken humor
nein es geht einfach nur darum wie
knackig sie sind auf einer skala von
eins bis rindswurst
hier kommt unsere männer jury die diese
jungs werden gleich über hort und flop
entscheiden
bestimmt die selbsteinschätzung der
mädels mit der schwierigen herten
die drei jungs natürlich auch absolute
brecher also deren sprüche und deren
einstellung zum leben und sich dann
einen schirm auf zu frauen trägt mit
dazu bei dass diese sendung so ist wie
sie ist davon werdet ihr gleich auch
noch zu genüge gesehen aber vielleicht
noch kurz als intro so für die
allgemeine konstellation die ist so so
die frauen die sich selbst ein und
stellt dann quasi so einzeln vor die
übermächtige jury und die jury drückt
den dann sprecherin
ring frei für die erste runde
das gesicht die mädels müssen jetzt
hätten wie die jungs die gleich
platzieren werden denn hier geht es
nicht darum was den damen gefällt die
meinung der jury muss eingeschätzt
werden was diese ganzen sachen noch ein
bisschen kritischer macht ist dass
frauen glaube ich heutzutage unserer
gesellschaft sowieso schon sehr sehr
kritisch mit den eigenen körpern sind
ich glaube kritische auch als meiner ich
habe letztens irgendwo gelesen ich weiß
nicht genau wo es war dass männer vor
allen dingen damit beschäftigt sind oder
kritisch mit sich selbst sind wenn es
darum geht kompetent zu sein irgendwie
viel stärker ausstrahlung wurde er wahr
und frauen sehr selbstkritisch sind wenn
es um die eigene attraktivität geht ja
da hat sie ein großer deutscher
fernsehsender den ich jetzt mal nicht
explizit nennen möchte gedacht okay wir
haben es die macher eine sendung in der
frauen ausschließlich anhand ihres
gesichts und ihres körpers verwertet
werden und versehen sie in dieser
sendung mit attributen die auch in der
bratwurst zugeschrieben werden fünf
knackige frauen
ich habe gedacht ein wichtig
grundsätzlich alle platz
er wird später zieht sich alles
irgendwie zusammen das ist wirklich das
ist wirklich fremdscham pur weil also
wie gesagt so das ganze passiert unter
dem vorzeichen unter dem kontext das
glaube ich frauen per se sehr
selbstkritisch sind mit ihrem körper so
und wir haben werde in diesem format
quasi die frauen nicht nur von den
männern kritisiert und das auch
teilweise echt schon harte weise sondern
kritisieren sich auch noch untereinander
und drücken sich dann so was rein wieso
also ich finde dein gesicht sollte auf
den letzten platz also wie gesagt ich
werde nicht der white knight sein der
bei jeder kleinigkeit sagte moment mal
das ist aber moralisch nicht in ordnung
aber das ist halt einfach schon too much
ich möchte schaut euch das mal an achtet
man auf die gesichtsausdrücke sind alle
übels am könnten auch sogar die blonde
die jetzt gerade im auf platz eins
gewählt wo man sich denken wir da so ok
wack an dass sich freuen die aus ja ja
ja ja ja dann bin ich platz eins bis
dato bekomme ich zu den eindruck dass
alle menschen in dieser sendung sie
einfach krass unwohl fühlen
[Musik]
ok also die form habe ich jetzt in der
ersten kategorie auf ihr rating geeinigt
haben sich entsprechend aufgestellt das
ganze sieht dann so aus hier nicht da
versteckt sich bei mir noch mehr der
eindruck dass diese ganze sendung
einfach so seltsam konzipiert ist kommt
man zum beispiel die männer sind
komplett angezogen die frauen sind halb
nackt so die frauen wissen sich selbst
gegenseitig und wenn dann noch von den
männern geht ist also ich hab mir auch
mal in die kommentare finde finde ich
dass ich übertreibe wenn ich so etwas
sage sagt ehrlich also ich finds wie ich
finde es seltsam auch keine kissen und
ein gekühltes diesen schrott allein
wieder anschauen wir hier sitzen so drei
vier fünf vielleicht sechs meter von den
mädels entfernt und unterhalten sich so
auch normale zimmer lautstärke darüber
was jetzt von deren rating und von deren
gesichtern halten so nach dem motto die
zwei ist voll lege sich zwölf meter
können wir auch gar keinen fall machen
also hören die frauen das nicht so
schwierig ist das sonst etwas weiter
vorne sagt so ne ne ne also ich finde ja
die zwei überhaupt nicht verdient so
ausdruckslos
aber es gibt mehrere zum spiel ich bin
mir sicher megageil im moment für sie
einfach mal vor millionen von zuschauern
im fernsehen gesagt bekommt dass man
einfach mal eine auswahl von personen
die meinen herumstehen einfach das
hässliche gesicht hat geil und ich
verwende das wort hässlich ist das jetzt
nicht weil ich denke das ist eine art
und weise ist in der man öffentlich über
menschen reden sollte sondern einfach
weil das letzten endes das ist was die
mit der 5 ausdrücken
zum bikini passt es jetzt oder ist es zu
viel für uns du bist unserer meinung
nach die zwei festliche in dieser runde
also die mit dem zweithöchsten gesicht
wie gesagt an dessen dann möchte ich
noch mal betont dass hier wirklich
millionen von leuten gerade zu schauen
bei dieser sendung und wollte einfach
mal fragen was du davon hält ich will
noch mal ganz deutlich sagen leute dass
ich glaube das ist schon relativ normal
ist dass man so über leute denkt also
dass man zum beispiel auch in seinem
kopf vergleich so zb die da vorne
persönlich vielleicht nicht so gut oder
das teil der gefällt mir nicht so ich
finde die deswegen besser aus ganz
normal im alltag das macht mir ein
permanent mit allen möglichen menschen
das war überhaupt nicht schlimm das ist
vollkommen normal und ich finde auch
wenn man das zum beispiel im
freundeskreis macht so mit engen
freunden sagt so der abt lästert über
die personen das ist okay aber so rund
um diese krasse oberflächlichkeit
einfach eine sendung zu machen und die
wahrscheinlich auch noch am helllichten
tag auf einem der größten deutschen
fernsehsender auszustrahlen
das ist wiederum eine andere sache aber
es gibt weiter leute jetzt geht es um
die beine oder wird ich habe gerade
gerade habe ich wirklich so einem
kleinen gefühls kick bekommen ich
versuche einfach gerade zu beschreiben
was das ist und zwar ich habe habt ihr
diese person auf platz fünf gerade
dieser frau ins gesicht gesehen habt ihr
den clinch gesehen dass sie zweimal
hintereinander einfach auf platz fünf
ist mir ist es gerade wirklich ins auge
gestochen
da habe ich mir gedacht so decker was
würdest du denken wenn jetzt zum
beispiel nicht eine fremde person stehen
würde sondern so seine eigene schwester
ihr wisst ja ich habe eine kleine
schwester
es geht einfach nicht klar so erst jetzt
wo ich mir vorstellen dass das den
menschen passiert der mir auch noch
persönlich nahe steht zudem ich
persönliche bezug habe da wird es
wirklich mal deutlich deutlich deutlich
ist das geht einfach nicht
also wählt ob das findet dieses format
geht 0,0 klar nächste kategorie leute
sexappeal und es wird immer schlimmer
[Musik]
für sap ist die beide alle drei noch mal
sagen guck mal silber sogar die drei
typen dir wirklich entweder sie sind
oder zumindest die rolle spielen von so
komplett herablassenden menschen selbst
diese drei typen haben mittlerweile
erkannt wie krejcik und wie herablassend
das gegenüber einem menschen ist kummer
sie ist jetzt zum dritten mal auf platz
fünf und jetzt diese drei typen sind
langsam so ja ja tut uns leid keine
ahnung ja ist schon nicht so geil was
wir hier machen gemerkt sind auch mal
langsam also noch fachleute
ich finde das richtig kacke jeder von
denen ist ein mensch mit artikel 1
grundgesetz in deutschland unantastbarer
menschenwürde und dann menschen im
fernsehen zu stellen zu sagen du bist da
am schlechtesten da am schlechtesten da
am schlechtesten kommt damit klar
[Musik]
aber ja leute das ist nur meine meinung
dazu schaffen dazu gerne und in die
kommentare und checkt hier ein für euch
vorschlagen wie die oft in einen kanal
abonnieren heute und ist ein einziges
video ich trotzdem gefallen und
christoph augen auf jeden fall macht's
gut
wir haben dich auf der 5 gesehen von der
jetzt richtig eingeschätzt aber nichts
damit zu tun hast du nicht ein absolut
hübsches mädchen ist hier die beide alle
drei noch mal sagen
verpiss dich